so I want to start with you
representative fine your reaction to
this news that the deputies were told
not to enter the building
without body cams which they lacked at
the time your reaction Thank You Laura
thanks for having me on look the more we
learn about this situation the more
obvious it is that Sheriff Israel needs
to be needs to resign or be removed
immediately that's why I sign that
letter and that's why the Florida House
is moving this week to subpoena all
records of Sheriff Israel and we're
going to be subpoena hang and making him
come up to Tallahassee to explain
himself what happened is a disgrace
mark I want to go to you on this the
report that we got tonight that some of
these radio communications are missing
or weren't recorded which I think are
very important are going to be critical
as we need to try to try to determine
what really happened in the aftermath
here what's your reaction to what we've
learned frankly just today and tonight
well it's pretty shocking that one that
even occurred and then two of the able
to find out any of this information but
what's interesting is sheriff Israel's a
character is a politician let's not
forget that but it really has nothing to
do with the actions of the deputies at
the scene I don't care if they had
radios I don't care if they were on or
off they should have done exactly what
they knew they had to do regardless of
who told them what to do over a radio
you ignore that and you go in and you
try to save the lives of those children
and you contact the shooter and killing
Terry let's go to you we're also
learning that in the training of some of
these police officers they were taught a
kind of D cot that you know deconflict
the situation so don't rush in assess
the situation first and a Scott
Peterson's attorney is also kind of
indicating that in some of his comments
we try to get him on the show tonight he
would not join us which is unfortunate
but if the police are being trained in a
way that is not really helpful in this
type of active shooter situation that
also is something we better find out
fast Laura that's against any protocol
that I've been aware of since Columbine
all officers that I'm
are always taught to go in don't be
stupid
but go in tactically but go in protect
the innocence there if they're being
trained that way I don't know why they
would be trained that way well one of
the reports we also heard rep fine is
that the the deputy on-site thought that
apparently some of the shooting was
taking place outside the building
because again radio transmission that I
think we may or may not have indicated
that someone was injured on or near the
football field and so that's one of the
reasons he stayed behind the cement
barrier or car and was just four minutes
went by and people were being shot one
after the other after the other in this
building so maybe it was just an honest
mistake I mean I don't know but it seems
like we should we should have a lot of
this video already publicly available
yeah and if sheriff Israel wasn't so
busy bloviating on CNN town halls we
might have some of those answers that's
why speaker Corcoran has asked us all to
support him and getting sheriff Israel
either to resign or to be removed that
should happen immediately mark fuhrman
there's a sound bat bite that I thought
of you when I heard this yesterday I
know I know you know which what it is
but I'll just read it I don't think we
have already but Jake Tapper basically
asked him about the Broward County
Sheriff's
you know reaction whether they had done
things differently would the shooting
have happened or not
and sheriff Israel says listen if and
buts were candy and nuts Oh Jay Simpson
would still be in the record books and
tappers like I don't know what that
means they're 17 people dead and a long
list of things he could have done
differently so he has this kind of glib
way of responding to questions and I
think you hit the nail on the head he's
more of a politician than someone to
head the largest Police Department
County Police Department in the country
with of its type of stature apparently I
didn't realize that it's the largest
largest Police Department in the country
I don't even understand how it can be
with New York and so forth but it's it
of its type I guess it's the largest
well Laura you know he seems awful
impressed with himself very flippant
almost like he doesn't see the gravity
of exactly what happened like it's an
opportunity for somebody to know his
first last name and all of his career
and but when he had to he had to
actually give up this information on the
deputy that was sitting outside of that
building number 12 listening to those
gunshots and I'm going to tell you right
now they knew full well that that
shooting was going on inside of that
building and I will guarantee something
for deputy Peterson or ex deputy
Peterson he will relive that four
minutes outside of that building for the
rest of his life that's for sure let's
go to Terry on this speaking of the need
for a real thorough investigation that's
that's not tainted or questioned could
the FBI or could the Justice Department
I should say could they conduct a real
investigation here given the fact that
the FBI clearly dropped the ball on
these on at least two of these tips and
the most recent one was really
disturbing involving mrs. de schampoo
was the woman who actually had him
living in in her house so could the
Justice Department really do this
investigation I believe they can Laura
but but the fundamental problem here is
the FBI has dropped the ball for the
last several years as I've mentioned to
a number of my colleagues and we've come
in at each of their own the the FBI no
longer communicates with the community
when you contact the FBI anymore even
myself as a retired FBI agent when I
call the FBI office I used to work at I
get a recording I don't speak to a human
being when I was an FBI agent we
answered the phone we talked to the the
people in the community we were there to
provide safety to that community and in
order to do that you have to be able to
communicate with them they have to be
able to speak with you as an agent a
trained agent not not an analyst not an
intake specialist but a special agent of
the FBI the FBI has tried to centralize
all of their activity for so long now
they've lost touch with the communities
that we're supposed to be
safety - that's the fundamental issue
whether DOJ can investigate that and
come up with a conclusion I'm certain
they can't but the FBI needs to look
within itself and it needs to start
providing the services the community
yeah a lot of problems law enforcement
is finding out that this 19 year old was
obsessed with Isis it had come in to
25,000 dollars buying all these guns and
it talked about shooting up a school and
ripping animals apart
I mean ding-ding-ding like you know all
the warning bells are kind of going off
there I mean I'm not an expert like you
guys in this but it's I mean I guess in
hindsight if you know you have 20/20
hindsight here but to me this is just
this is a wild situation why do you wrap
it up look you know when the FBI got
that tip on Nicholas Cruz spelled a very
specific way that he was a possible
school shooter all he all that that FBI
agent had to do is go to a federal
database for gun registration and just
find out if a Nicholas Cruz had
purchased any weapons lo and behold it
would have popped up he's out an ar-15
he's in parkland Florida go door knock
it fantastic guys would appreciate a
great panel and and by the way President
Trump had really harsh words today for